so Punisher MAX has one of the greatest
moments ever for Frank Castle in the
history of Marvel Comics check this out
so during Punisher MAX you had a story
arc called the slavers and this
basically dealt with Frank Castle coming
to the realization there was a whole
slave trade taking place in the city of
New York so Frank Castle ends up
realizing that the whole operation is
ran by a guy named Tiberia who in turn
is answering to these old school guys in
Romania and these are old hat these are
the guys who only understand two things
violence and power and so Frank Castle
basically being both ends up working his
way up the ranks killing everybody he
can all the way to the point of getting
to type here you then he takes tiberio
he ties him down to a chair he sets up a
video camera he hits record he douses
the guy in gasoline and then sets him on
fire alive and then he looks into the
camera and he says don't come back then
he takes the footage and he sends it off
to the guys in Romania and you know what
they do they never come back make sure
you guys follow for more